hey guys cam here now what's your
favorite example of hacking in video
games now watchdogs has recently taken
the hacking fiction to a whole new level
making the foundation of the game but
hacking has been a near staple of
futuristic sci-fi titles for a long time
and its implementation is about as
varied as the games themselves sometimes
breaking into a system requires you to
get a password other times it's all
about taking over nodes on a computer
and then on occasions it's about
directing metallic liquid through pipes
yeah I don't know why either but which
game does it best or worst and do any of
them resemble real life hacking to help
me with this week's reality check
question i sat there with a hacking
expert chris boyd you might remember him
from such episodes as crude watchdogs be
real and they're this one he's a
computer security researcher and malware
intelligence analyst for malwarebytes
and there was a thing or two about
hacking in games hell he even once
identified a significant vulnerability
in the Steam client and gave valve the
heads-up Todd man so I asked him to tell
me about his favorite hacking moments in
video games there was a game many years
ago end to the end to the matrix
spinoff from the Matrix trilogy and that
had this this kind of cool user terminal
that was built into the game and as you
progress through the game you could hack
the terminal and the the machine world
if you like to give you a character
extra skills abilities and it was it was
kind of true to sort of real-life
hacking as far as the the films went and
it was a very very clever tie-in and it
just seemed to work with the the game
world that they built very well okay so
that's the good but what about the bad
now well bioshock strange liquid pipe
system must give a nod for being the
weirdest and perhaps least plausible
hacking system ever in a game i don't
think it's the worst by any means so I
asked Chris his opinion on the worst
hacking in games
a really good game that I like not many
people like this one blues game called
Alpha Protocol sort of really clever
open-ended spy game but it made the
mistake of trying to be too literal kind
of with its hacking and it was terrible
if you logged into a terminal to hack it
you've got this green screen of ones and
zeros and various other numbers and all
of these numbers are constantly changing
on the screen and you've got something
like a 10-second time limit to move one
set of numbers on the right and one set
of numbers on the left to the point
where they both meet over the one place
on this flashing wall of numbers that
was completely static and it was as bad
as it sounds it was absolutely terrible
one of the first things you end up
having to do while you're breaking out
of this lab is this hacking minigame and
it just stopped me dead I couldn't I
couldn't even work out how to do it
there was no real tutorial for it and I
just put the game away for about you
know five months I think because I just
couldn't work this thing out I tried
that must have tried for about an hour
gave off and it was only after I went
back and forced myself to get through
this awful mini game the rest this game
open and it was it was wonderful but
I've never seen the game so neat very
nearly sculpted completely by this one
terrible ten-second minigame now even
though hacking in games is extremely
varied there is one consistent trope in
every hacking system that I can think of
anyway time limits but is this based on
reality or just a video game mechanic
used to add challenge and tension I'm to
some degree yeah I mean in the games
it's more of an arbitrary you know
20-second 30-second limit just because
you'd be able to sit there and hack all
day and you know in reality someone goes
and breaks into a server if there's a
lot of variables that may or may not
have a big impact so they may know that
someone is checking this information all
the time there might be a really hot so
ever admin that's always looking at this
thing because he's nervous in case
someone's trying to break into it but
generally speaking if you know that this
the server that you're trying to break
into is on the other side of the globe
and you're gonna do when they're all in
bed the sleeve the system's gonna pick
it up but there may not be someone on
the other end watching it in real time
but more of a concern for people more
than time limits is just trying to get
in and out without being noticed at all
it doesn't really matter if they spend a
little bit of time in there or a lot of
time as long as they they know how to
cover the tracks and make it look like
there was nobody there that's that's
really the building's objective Deus Ex
Human Revolution this has to be my
personal favorite example of hacking in
any game I've played the system is
actually pretty fun
very tense due to be occurring in real
time and also requires a degree of skill
but what does Kris make of it and is it
grounded in reality the deus ex games go
down the path of many games do when they
have to have some hacking in there
because it can't be too true-to-life
because people would either be
completely confused or bored to tears so
they go down this minigame Ruth and
admittedly you're still watching little
icons move up a thing and then move move
this way and but it's a lot more grander
than what the concept of this futuristic
type of hacking would be and the deus ex
games are good because you can social
engineer a lot of the passwords from
computer terminals from random
conversations that you've overheard from
bits and pieces of information picked up
in the game world so it gets to the
stage where you don't actually have to
go through the the eventually kind of
tiresome hacking minigame you can just
get on there fill in the login details
and be away with the information you
need now for me this gives Deus Ex Human
Revolution that additional degree of
realism because ultimately in real life
hacking often comes down to this social
engineering that Chris mentioned in the
real world the best way to gain access
to server se is always to get hold of
genuine login details this is often
achieved by simple things like phishing
emails so if a hacker can prompt
somebody to unwittingly divulge their
username and password then their job
becomes so much easier but as Chris
explained to me hacking comes in loads
of different forms
and techniques unfortunately is pretty
random I mean there's always going to be
a set of fixed variables for certain
types of systems that someone's going to
break into how it runs this operating
system oh it's this kind of platform but
you know there's just as many hacks for
every hack that's out there 30 a really
clever really sophisticated very elegant
and you look at it the day after when it
hits the news and think wow how did they
come up with that one
there's lots of script kiddies who sit
there with some tool that someone else
made they don't know how it works they
don't know how to run air they just know
that they have to push the big red
button and it will go off and find the
information that they think they need so
it's very random I can there can be a
lot of skill involved they can be a
complete absence of skill involved so
tell me what are your personal best and
worst of hacking in video games then I
put this question there over Twitter
before recording the episode and I got a
bunch of great responses which you can
see right now but do keep them coming
you can let me know on twitter at cam
for Azeroth or just by dropping me a
comment in the box below thanks for
watching as always guys I'll see you
back here next week for more reality
check
you